IS YOU DON'T CARE.
I HOPE YOU COME BACK --
>> I WOULD LOVE TO, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WE WANT TO END TO
THAT WITH GREAT NEWS.
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF IT, BUT THIS
IS GREAT.
THIS IS KELLY McNALLY.
WHENEVER YOU SEE PEOPLE ON THEIR
SHOW AND WONDER WHO CONVINCED
THEM THE COMING YEAR, IT WAS
LIKELY CAPPY       KELLY McNALLY
LIKELY CAPPY       KELLY McNALL.
SHE'S THAT NICE.
SHE MARRIED HER MATCH.
SHE'S ALSO UNIVERSALLY LOVE
HERE.
KELLY AND RAY WERE MARRIED AT
THE CHURCH OF THE EPIPHANY IN
MIAMI, SO WE HEADED DOWN TO
CHEER THEM ON.
IS THERE ANYTHING BETTER THAN
SEEING GOOD PEOPLE MARRY EACH
OTHER?
CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING.
IT WAS WONDERFUL.
CONGRATULATIONS TO KELLY AND
RAY.